this video is sponsored by skillshare
the first 200 people to use the link in
the description
get their first two months free uber is
the highest valued private company
in the world more than airbnb spacex and
lyft
combined every day 15 million rides are
taken across 600 cities in 78 countries
everywhere from the southern tip of
africa to the tiny town of gridley
california
home of the red suspenders festival i'm
sure you're familiar
uber is so successful because it's so
convenient
open the app and choose a ride standard
or luxury
or in india rickshaw soon even flying
taxi
afterwards you rate the driver and they
rate you
one through four stars being the worst
experience of your life
and 5 stars anywhere from mostly
tolerable to
absolutely amazing i'm only slightly
kidding a 4.6
average can get a driver deactivated
still better than netflix's thumbs up or
down which is eighty percent
sure a like the emoji movie to which i
say
finally uber calculates the price it's
really very simple
start with a regular base fare add the
per minute rate multiplied by time spent
in car
plus distance times the per mile rate
all of which depend on the city a 40
ride in tokyo costs a dollar 62 in cairo
then add the booking fee and possibly
airport toll cancellation cleaning and
lost item fees
unless there are too many riders and not
enough drivers
in which case multiply by a surge price
2 3
or on new year's eve 2011 seven times
the normal price
and as youtubers have shown algorithms
can be manipulated if drivers log out at
the same time
they create a shortage and trigger a
surge oh it also uses machine learning
to predict how much you're willing to
pay based on route so maybe don't call
an uber from the burj khalifa to the
bellagio besides the fact that you
can't even despite this uber is almost
always
cheaper faster and easier it took the
most outdated
inefficient industry sprinkled in
something called technology and
completely
reinvented the wheel oh come on you
should know by now
there's always a twist
in the 1930s the great depression
happened
it wasn't great but it was depressing
every fourth american
was unemployed and desperate for work
especially
low skill low barrier to entry jobs but
youtube hadn't been invented so they
drove taxis
lots and lots of taxis meanwhile fewer
people could afford a ride
and as i was taught by a monopoly
educating me about the danger of
monopolies when this line goes up and
this one goes down
prices fall and drivers get angry like
violent protests and the street angry so
new york city wrote the haas act
now to legally operate a taxi you'd need
one of 17 000 licenses
called medallions but 81 years later
with a million
more people it's only 13 000. you can
see the problem
the number of medallions issued is more
political than it is practical
before extreme competition made prices
unsustainably low
good for riders bad for drivers and then
the pendulum reversed
too little competition made taxis
expensive and inefficient
bad for writers good for drivers one
medallion
the right to operate a single taxi was
once worth over a million dollars
but advice like this hasn't aged so well
because
uber happened its drivers flood the
market by not requiring medallions
draining their value high competition
low prices
and angry calls for regulation sound
familiar
this time we aren't in an economic
depression but many households are
which means lots of drivers for you and
i uber is revolutionary
the low prices of last century plus the
magic of these things
and for drivers well yes and no
if you ask uber what the average driver
makes an hour
they point you to this study 19.19
another says 21. not too bad unless you
look under the hood
what they don't include are the car its
depreciation
maintenance gas and some of the
insurance adjust for these
and things aren't so rosy this study
estimates the median hourly profit
is 8.55 before taxes less than minimum
wage for 54
of drivers eight percent actually lose
money you might say
but uber is supplementary a quick way to
make some extra cash between
jobs and that's mostly true about 60
percent have another primary income
plus unlike taxis who are even legally
required to wear black socks in la
with uber you have some freedom but the
reason people don't drive more
might only be they can't because uber
considers its drivers
not employees but independent
contractors
employees are entitled to minimum wage
gas reimbursement overtime
breaks collective bargaining paid leave
and health insurance
which would cost the company about four
billion dollars a year
so they're extremely careful to call
drivers partners
and itself not a transportation company
but a platform
simply connecting riders to drivers who
decide when to work
what to wear and so on but uber controls
the prices
and that's the catch if drivers are just
independent businesses
uber setting their fares could be
considered price fixing
so which are they that depends on who
you ask and when
and the answer will shape the future of
the industry but something doesn't add
up
the golden age for drivers came from
regulating competition the same
regulation uber spends millions of
dollars fighting
going back to the days of high
competition and low prices
but why if uber takes a cut from drivers
their interests should be the same
regulation of course
slows its growth but there's also
another reason
drivers compete but uber makes the same
commission
regardless of who picks you up uber
makes more money with more drivers
but drivers want the opposite less
competition they look like other
platform vendor relationships
amazon and its sellers apple and app
developers both of which need their
vendors
if youtube leaves the app store apple
can't replace it
but drivers are drivers uber needs them
but no one
in particular they're disposable
something like 96
stopped driving for the company in their
first year the two
seem economically intertwined but as
long as uber can find
more drivers they can keep fares
unsustainably competitive with rivals
the real winners of the haas act weren't
cab drivers who can't afford
million dollar medallions but their
owners instead of drivers giving away
their first 100
a day to rent a medallion now it's 25
all day for many drivers it's still a
very welcome and useful opportunity
but it isn't quite the groundbreaking
revolution promised
and it may not last
[Music]
on paper uber has the perfect business
model
its huge network of drivers dominate the
globe but it need not buy a single car
or gallon of fuel
all perk and no work something thousands
of startups desperately try to emulate
most of which belong on flopstarter with
products like the timeless watch which
doesn't tell the time so how did uber
lose four and a half billion dollars
last year
that's 12 million dollars a day many
startups sacrifice profit for growth but
uber is nine years old
facebook made money after two the
company's biggest problem
may not be its legality or controversy
although there's plenty of that
but basic holes in its business model
the magic of so many companies is the
network effect
every new customer makes it that much
easier to get
another you join facebook because steve
is on it kim joins facebook because you
are
and so on for uber though this is only
regional
more drivers in new york does nothing
for beijing
in fact it failed in all of china every
city is a new chicken and egg problem
drivers need riders before they'll drive
and riders need drivers before they'll
ride
i do not like them sam i am i do not
like green eggs and oh
this helps keep prices low and profits
non-existent
it's inescapable and leaves only one
path for uber
self-driving cars remove the driver
remove the money eating machine
but it means competing with the
technology of google and the auto
expertise of gm
either it'll transform into one of the
biggest transportation companies in the
world
or it'll be the end of the road it plans
to go public next year which will be
fascinating to watch
doubly so if you understand the basics
of the stock market a great way to learn
is with skillshare
this course explains investing starting
with the basics and it's taught by my
friends over at business casual a great
channel i've collaborated with before
i've personally watched the course and
it really is a nice
concise introduction better yet it's
presented in a series of well-produced
animated videos you're not watching
someone talk
over a powerpoint and that's what's so
great about skillshare
you learn from the experts in a way that
you actually want to keep going back to
it pays to invest in yourself today so
you can be a good
investor tomorrow maybe you're inspired
to start your own business or just see
what it's like
classes like this one cover how an idea
becomes a business
and how you can get into the
entrepreneur mindset there are over 20
000 courses from cooking to making
animated videos
like this one a premium membership gives
you unlimited access to all of them
and the first 500 people to use the link
in the description
get two months totally free thanks to
skillshare for supporting this show
and to you for listening oh by the way
i hope you like the new logo as much as
i do i'd love to hear from you on my
newly improved
subreddit and discord